okay and we are live
hello and welcome to round table with
the stream team and this is where we end
up speaking to content creators and
about their journey and what they've
been doing and how things are working
out for them and you know all that fun
stuff getting to know with that content
creator a little more personal and today
we have our friend from wicked games
Papa Tom how are you doing I am doing
great
thank you for having me on always good
to be rockin with the iron Lords podcast
and you know it's good you know another
beautiful day in the neighborhood
another beautiful day stuck inside so
stuck inside seen the amazing four walls
that are around you well thank you very
much for taking your time you know to
come and spend some time with us so we
have our other two amazing panels today
we have MJ is a boss what's going on in
J how are you yeah oh I'm pretty good
I'm doing well you know I had to go into
the office today but you know sometimes
you got to do what you got to do you
know but at least the commute is still
awesome I will take a 45-minute commute
over an hour and 45 minutes any day of
the week so it is it is good it is good
as well how are you how is classes for
you classes still rolling two weeks two
counting down oh yeah man I remember
those days counting down crossing the
fingers
exactly exactly well thank you for you
know being able to come today and we
have l-boogie Oh - oh eight how are you
hey how you doing how's your week been
so far it's okay so far we and close to
the end of our sprint and release lots
of moving parts at work oh well thank
you I know you're very busy and I really
appreciate you being able to come and
you know sit on the panel and yeah I
want to also say hello to Chris who's
been sitting in chat under the wiki game
and said what's going on man we will be
seeing Hugh in a couple of weeks also
hopefully fingers crossed with some
timing
and everyone knows myself it is just now
though here you know me just hanging out
chilling and but we are all here for one
reason and one reason alone and that is
poppadom so why don't you go ahead and
tell us your you know your thoughts and
journeys on being a content creator and
you know we like we were discussing
before we are doing a little expose if
you will on the Wiggio gaming crew so
we're gonna be having you Chris and dr.
Bob all and then we're gonna have all
you guys at one time
at the end so we'll hear the full week
of you gaming you know background so
which is very exciting so good and tell
us about yourself and while you were
doing everything oh yeah yeah so if you
don't know me like my handle the go-by
poppadom or just dom is totally fine
uncle Donnie it depends on who you ask
you know you can find us over at wicked
good gaming com not another gaming
podcast is available everywhere you get
fine curated you know a handcrafted
podcast you know the real top-shelf
stuff you you might have seen me
probably on the podcast you might see me
on our twitch page on youtube we do some
YouTube videos here and that we kind of
cover a little bit of everything so we
it's it's kind of weird because when I
whenever we get like I mean this this
year impacts for example I mean just to
kind of like put it into perspective we
got assigned these like content creator
badges instead of just the regular media
and it's weird because I've kind of
never really thought of us as either of
those you know I'd consider us more like
personalities or just more like regular
guys and that's kind of the babies yeah
yeah we definitely have some and that's
kind of the way that I've always thought
about it as for me personally I've
actually been writing about games for I
want to say I mean we're coming up on
it's gonna be seven or eight years at
this point I initially started writing
about I've been to every PAX East and
around the first one I met the people
from rebel gaming stuff and Rob who run
rebel gaming they had me write some
blogs for them you know I was in college
at the time and I didn't really keep up
with it as much but I you know started
up but kind of a
persona and obviously like having a bit
of a profile with blogs and things like
that I didn't really stream much
streaming has never been my thing but a
couple you know one to skip a few end up
kind of linking up with Chris and Robb
who are some hometown buddies of mine
you know we've known each other for
years and we all we all like video games
so we kind of just ended up finding out
that you know whenever we get together
we have a couple beers we end up talking
about games like let's put it down on
wax let's start recording it so
initially the idea was man we should
start a podcast me and Bob started
talking about that's we played we've
played Dungeons and Dragons every Monday
for the last five years the same group
of guys so me and Bob were talking about
like what if we did a podcast like what
if we what people listen to it and my
initial thought was no nobody would
listen to it because we they have no
[ __ ] idea who we are so the idea was
to start the website for a start wicked
good gaming and so I looped in Chris who
him and I had just become coworkers
actually but obviously we've known each
other forever
I knew he knew how to build websites and
so I had looped him in there to provide
you know that part of the expertise and
to you know obviously to consider
contributor as well and then all of our
roles have kind of evolved over the
years so for the majority of nine of the
gaming podcast I've been the primary
host you know done I've done them you
know the majority of the guest outreach
and also all the design for the website
Bob is our primary streamer and video
content creator he does an awesome job
with our YouTube page he's been really
building that out over the last couple
of months and he's been actually
stepping up his editing game up a lot
more too so that's been really cool to
see and then chris is a primarily the
social guy so he's completely built out
our socials from the ground up from
absolute dog [ __ ] nothing and oh wait am
I allowed to swear on this one I
couldn't swear a matter I completely
forgot about that cuz I definitely swore
in the first literal millisecond of my
episodes podcast so I just didn't want
to like mess up your clean tag no like I
said as long as you're not going off for
20 minutes with curse words we're
perfectly fine yeah no that's alright we
do that on our show we do
on our podcast every Thursday at which
TV slash wicked gaming but yeah so we
all have
oh no ideas no shame in it so we all
kind of have our different pillars that
we that we take care of but all of us
have one focused goal that's just kind
of like take the brand to the moon you
know what I mean like we've just we've
built an awesome community and I discord
shout out to everybody in the discord
and you know I'm really proud of the
people that that we've brought together
we've done multiple like in-person
meetups too through whether it was PAX
East or we just got a bunch of local
people together at our like a brewery
and it's just been kind of crazy to see
like people that we would otherwise
never have met come together just
through video games so yeah I mean in a
roundabout way we are content creators
but we're not we're just kind of like
regular guys and that's the vibe that we
try to bring to every episode of the
show is just like being genuine being
like you know your buddies that you meet
up with for a couple drinks to talk
about games and just talk shop and you
know we keep things light we keep things
casual we keep things genuine so that's
us
yeah that's it's kinda funny because the
way we met was we kind of met briefly in
passing impacts like I think on the show
floor we ended up just like meeting each
other because I thought the way the
teams worked was I was with cog and you
know you guys do stuff vastly different
than we do like we do everything with
video with with it with with the
interviews and things like that and then
like we just happen to pass and you you
told us on Thursday night and you were
like hey we're doing a podcast you guys
should just come on in and I like pretty
much just walked in and I know that you
and the guys were like who is this guy
we have no idea he was you had to do my
intro off the spot and you know you guys
were amazing
of that though was it I killed that dog
you did you did kill that it was very it
was it was like literally right off the
cuff and you guys like made it very very
warm and very like you know inviting to
person who has never ever been you know
kind of met you guys and it was nice and
I wanted to say thank you for that so
yeah that's how we are doing it's I mean
you saw me I was like dude get in here
like get on this episode of
we're just gonna start recording it I
saw Dave in the in the hallway and I was
like yeah we're gonna start recording
yeah I would have brought one of the
janitors in from outside the hotdog
stands the guy in the boom-boom room in
the corner yeah the thing this is that
that was probably one of the funnest
episodes I've ever been part of like
period because it was just let's just
messing around and goofing off and yes
and you guys didn't even have liquor in
you which is like yeah which is like one
of your kind of like one of the staples
of your shows if you will that's true
yeah you need to see that's you got to
see that side of us later that evening
oh yes we did and that was that was a
lot of fun it was really good so uh so
tell us about yourself who now who's
poppadom Mikey now you know you have to
you have the show many people know you
know you you've gone through you that
you're married with the wife and
everything like that and you you know
how does she feel that you cuz you guys
have been together for for how long no
for a long time
so when you told her hey we're gonna be
ending up doing this this website and
this you know we're gonna start doing
these podcasts and things like that what
was her reaction when you when you
decided to do that yeah so I mean in
general I think that we've always
supported each other's like passion
projects and hobbies and stuff like that
and you know before we even like moved
in together oh we were already like
workshopping the idea to start the show
she knows Chris and Rob really well they
were groomsmen in my wedding I mean
they're really close personal friends so
it's not like you know it's not like she
doesn't know who's who's involved with
the with the whole program so she's been
really supportive of it you know and I
also I mean that was a big video game
guide for I've been a big you know video
game guy for my entire life so she
didn't this is nothing like out of the
ordinary this is nothing that's like
surprising or shocking in any way
because it's just like yeah I'm gonna go
talk about games on the internet with my
friends for a little bit and you know I
like to think that I do a good job of
balancing my time with kind of all
aspects of life for me and you know with
the nine-to-five with the you know the
show the brand you know with her with
the social life you know it's all that
stuff is really a poor
and if what I told Chris and Rob from
day one was if we're gonna do this we
need to do it consistently we need to do
it every week same time same you know
episode length and you know we can
innovate we can do it longer we could
kind of like mess around with that but
we need to have a foundation that people
can rely on and that's actually helped
me to help balance out everything else
around the show so yeah I mean it's just
one of those things it's like now it's
just a part of my weekly routine which
is like hey every Thursday night for an
hour and change
I'm gonna go [ __ ] with the guys on
the internet for a little bit I'll be
back you know I mean and I think she
usually watches Grey's Anatomy or
something like that during that time so
but we do gain together once in a while
so that's always fun but yeah she's that
like accidental I've walked into a
couple of episodes if you watch that's
always funny which is just like what do
you people talking about
yeah right I think she gets it by now
yes yes yes you so you said like you
know you you game a lot so what is your
gaming preference because I can tell you
right now and I know L and MJ will love
this one you are obsessed with Animal
Crossing yeah I'm a big animal crossing
guy everybody knows that I'm you know
hitting the the stock market hug across
the ten million bail mark on the stock
market with New Horizons already so you
know I'm grindin I've built out a quite
the bail turnip Empire over on Rangoon
Island and you can read the column on
wicked good gaming comm called mad bells
where I walk you through different
strategies on how to maximize your
income and new horizons you can check
that out so a weekly column we do the
new addition that that's what we're
gonna go tomorrow and we just kind of
talk about the ups and downs is the
stock market but I like I like
everything that I am like an
equal-opportunity gamer you know they
mean and I will play racing games
fighting games sports game whatever it
is I'm a big role-playing game guy I
like to really sink my teeth into one
thing and like latch on to it for a
hundred hours you know anything that I
can like soak up the lore with it I mean
I've been a big Warcraft guy since Wow
launched in 2000
for that was like freshman year of high
school for me so all my buddies were
playing it and we dug into that like
crazy so to play wow yeah yeah I still
play love to talk afterwards yeah it's
been off and on it's mostly off right
now I'm playing ESO right now which I
really like I think ESO is fantastic
you know destiny I mean I'm not
I can't even scratch the surface with
destiny with you guys I know this is a
big destiny Network but you know destiny
is also a game that I've spent a ton of
time with the whole Elder Scrolls series
yeah so I mean and I'm a big Nintendo
guy - I'm probably our biggest Nintendo
guy at the at wgg so anything to intend
those who I'm a big fan of yeah so um
mostly Martine how you doing man just
saw him saying what's going on so uh the
the other thing about it it's like ESO
for me like I thought yeah so and I was
like I want to fight a dragon
I literally logged in did the entrance
to the game I popped out of the other
side I saw a dragon
I killed the dragon I was like I am done
I can differ a lot back in it was like I
bought the game for about like an hour's
worth of time and it's like one of those
things I want to go back and I want to
play it because I know that there is so
much content it's so good
it's so worth it so yeah it's pretty
good the new the new episode I'm sorry
the new chapter that was implemented the
whole elsewhere chapter where they
implemented the Dragons back into the
game is awesome now they got the whole
dark Hado Skyrim expansion going on
right now which is though also I I
didn't realize when you called out the
chat I had my thing set the top chat and
I said sure showed me no messages and I
suppose it's alive and realized that I
missed like 20 messages so gotta to jbu
shout out to Steve shut up to Florida
man friend's house Chris we're also in
his honor it's just Christmas okay so
like you're saying with uh with with
Animal Crossing now Lu you could
probably talk about this more than me
like what is your intrigue and love and
and for playing that or is it
one of those things that it's like a hot
thing for you right now Dom we're
talking about say that she could
probably talk about it a little more oh
I thought you were asking well then it's
not for me well let's get it was kind of
like I had a question right for done
like what like what is your intrigue
about the game that can kind of like
that you can why you're so intrigued and
pulled by it and I was hoping L can kind
of answer because I don't know a switch
and I remember I told you it's like
along the same lines it's like the Sims
and stuff like that you know it's just
like one of those games that you could
just kind of zone out yeah it's relaxing
and I think it's really it's a nice
little stress reliever you know it's
it's one of those games that like this
all this like never really I feel this
there's never like a bad day when you
play in that game like you can pick up
cod or you can pick up a pack so you can
pick up whatever and have a couple
shitty games and that could be like a
day ruin you know I mean you ragequit I
was playing fallout 76 earlier and I
like couldn't just couldn't get out of
my own way lost a bunch of [ __ ] and quit
I just I just swore again I'm sorry and
but that I was like I can't this is that
this is a move ruined I pick up Animal
Crossing there's no such thing as a bad
session when you play that game I've
been playing those games since GameCube
I mean since the original one
I mean Animal Crossing is awesome I mean
it was a game that I played with my
siblings a lot growing up the first one
came out when I was like 10
I played the one on 3d guess as well I
never got into pocket camp I didn't have
a Wii U so I didn't play what was the
one on Wii U wild world I think but New
Horizons is awesome and it's a it's a
long-awaited return for me just just
it's a casual relaxing game and L could
hit the nail on the head I usually tell
people it's like The Sims except all
your neighbors are animals and you know
you can craft stuff you can kind of like
customize things and you can take it at
your own pace you can do you could log
in go and pick flowers and weeds or
something for 35 minutes and fish for a
little bit get objectively get get
nothing done in the game and still feel
pretty good or
you could go in like I did today which
was go and go out of your way to find an
island that sells that is buying turnips
at a really high rate
thanks to discord in Twitter and sell
them for you know 10 times the profit
make 4 million bells in one sitting
feel like you're breaking the game get
like that endorphin rush that goes
absolutely crazy when you go and you
stick it to that raccoon who's got you
ten million bells in debt from the start
of the game and it's just nothing better
is that absolute swindler Tom Nook and I
mean the guy thinks he's got you over a
barrel from the first from the first
time that you open up the game yeah
until you listen you say listen you
didn't know that I was the the the the
the turnip game to Walter White thing
insane amounts of turnips and I keep
forgetting to like go buy turnips and
it's really bad oh yeah
oh yeah because when I was doing it like
for a couple of weeks and I haven't
really been like playing it but yeah
yeah I was finding the money Ireland's
only on and I didn't find as a tarantula
Ireland every time I find a tarantula I
scream like you know they come at you
like it's surprising the very first time
you like and every time you think you
got one too they they you know I'm
pretty good yeah so I mean that's one of
those things I mean Animal Crossing we
were talking about it when we did our
episode of the show with you and the
other guys it's one of those games where
if you don't get it like I can't blame
you but like you should everybody should
give it a try even if you don't play
games you should give it a try see if
you like it you know it's relaxing it's
like a good little kind of palate
cleanser and it's so much different than
it's so different than everything else
out there I know a lot of people like
stardew valley or like Harvest Moon and
stuff like that and it's kind of similar
that it's a little less intense
I know stardew valley is like famously
pretty unforgiving and so in certain
ways and I think Harvest Moon is a lot
more challenging to I've never really
dug into it but it has a kind of a
similar vibe to those games as well if
you want to see one of the funniest
videos ever and if Chris is hearing me
right now it was when he yelled at Tom
looking cold
a crook wall at PAX East and you
instantly when you when you see him
scream it you see all the Nintendo
people just snap their heads looking
right at Chris in the camera like did
this guy just really yell at Tom look
and tell him he's a crook like that was
a cool one of those things that I was I
was dying out yeah yeah the Nintendo
employees that were the Nintendo
employees that was standing there or
like the poor people that were just like
working the booth
we're like what is going on right now
I'm gonna have to call security instant
detain this kid but ya knows uh pax was
really good excuse me
so something I did notice with you was
you did start to me a little streaming
because I did see you do a little
streaming of what's called magic yeah so
yeah MTG arena I started I just I
strained it a couple times recently yeah
so how how do you feel that is a little
different than you having to do your
podcast like um honestly and I've told
the guys this to like I think Chris kind
of feels similarly to to me in this
regard well like I don't love streaming
just because I don't like being on stage
all the time I feel like when we do the
podcast I've got I know exactly what I
need to do you know I I very rarely turn
this off this you know but like I don't
I also don't like being on state like I
when I sit and I'm like playing anything
like I'm usually like this like all the
way down in my chair like and I look
like you know I could fall asleep at any
second cuz I'm just my brain is
basically off um but then I got a you
know I don't mind engaging with people
but I do feel bad if I for some reason
like miss looking at the chat for a
minute or you know if things don't look
right or whatever and then I like my
eyes drift over to the screen like
looking at myself and I realize that
like my my like jaw has been hanging
open and I'm just like what cook I'm
catching fire they're not even paying
attention you know I mean so for me like
I have no problem gaming with people in
talking to them at the same time it's
not it's just like I don't know if
you're getting 100% of the best of me
sometimes if you're streaming I'm just
not
doing it so I actually used to stream a
lot of hearthstone when I used to be
really big in the house stone so you
might be not as surprised to know that
like now that I'm playing MTG arena like
I'm streaming that again because I don't
have to be doing something at every
every second I was streaming Wow
and like with wow like I like to sit
there and I like to read the quest text
and I like to watch the cutscenes and I
just want to like soak in the lore and I
don't want to like I'm not bad a you
know I don't think that's entertaining I
would not I do not find it entertaining
to watch people play Wow or ESO or
whatever I don't really find it
entertaining to watch that stuff I do
think it's entertaining to watch ntg
arena I think it's insane to watch
hearthstone I actually watched a little
Elder Scrolls legends that I like
watching the card game because you can
kind of see what's about to happen
same way some people might feel about
watching Valerie right now or watching
overwatch or watching csgo because you
can kind of anticipate the different
plays that they're gonna make if I'm
watching somebody play awhile and just
kind of wander around I'm just I
wouldn't want to watch that so then when
I stream it I'm like people don't want
to watch this [ __ ] like that I'm just
you know so that kind of takes away from
from you your enjoyment level of the
game uh certain games yeah I just like
for WoW I think that's that's my time
that's poppadom time I need to I need to
have that time you know what I mean like
if I'm playing
even if I'm playing animal crossing if I
had the capability to switch stream with
my switch right now I don't have a
stream deck but if I did and I I would
not want to play animal crossing and
strain there's I wouldn't want to do
that because then that's that's just
like you know you ever let me put it to
you this way if you're ever like playing
a game and the screen goes black and
then you see your reflection in this in
the monitor and you see how like
schlubby you look for a second like
that's how I feel when I'm streaming and
I'm like this is this what I look like
right now like you know what I mean I
don't know it's just for some games yes
hearthstone or magic if I'm like taking
it slow and I have people who are
engaging in the chat and they're like
talking
being like we should play that card or
like what does that card do I don't mind
talking about it I think that's I think
that's really fun
but for games like wow or like even like
csgo or something like that or you know
from playing a shoot or whatever like I
like to have that that's me that's my
time I don't know if I want to share
that with anybody I have no problem
jumping in one of our discord chats with
15 other people and all of us is over
and through and to each other because I
love playing games with friends but I
also just don't want to have to kind of
divide my like do like double duty
because then I feel like I'm not doing
either of them particularly well and
that's something that's just not that's
like not my brand you know right right
like a l do do you feel kind of that
similar way when you're when you're
playing games when you're streaming yeah
there's no way I'd want a stream Animal
Crossing either it's just like oh I mean
I see people doing it but I don't know I
feel like I'm like you like I feel like
I have to pay attention to chat and you
zone like you would think you a zone out
less yeah I'm like a shooter but you you
know are able to take like breaks or
whatever but when you're with Animal
Crossing it's just like I don't know
yeah if yeah I mean I like playing what
I like and I like streaming occasionally
I'll do it like when I'm bored if I have
some time I'll strain you know arena and
I'll probably do that more often and
maybe if I can get a little bit more
into it and obviously get better at it
too because nobody wants to like watch
somebody just suck
look they're funny that's good yeah
right and and that's the thing is like I
don't know if I have the time to like or
I don't know if I have like the
bandwidth to all the time like be
entertaining and be good at the same
time you know what I'm saying
and this certain people who all watch
the game play just different curious
about it and we've talked about this on
our show a bunch of times where it's
like I'll watch somebody stream a game
before I read a review for it cuz I'd
rather just see how it plays I don't
really like I think doctor disrespect is
entertaining and he's pretty much like
this like on a short list of maybe
people like on that I can count on one
hand who I enjoy watching streams
regularly because it's like oh this is
really fun you know like this is a you
know it's weird I don't know I think
there's a big difference between you
know especially if the if you know the
person that's streaming like watching
their personality on stream and then
knowing how they really are like if
you're just in like a group chat with
them or like a party chat with them and
you know I don't know if I want to make
I don't know if I want to make people
choose between those versions of me if
that makes sense so do you feel like
more like when you when your search
streaming you have to almost produce
like a persona yes I know because you
cuz you don't because you don't like you
don't you want to feel like yourself but
you can't exactly be yourself because
you have to end up kind of having them
see you in a certain way like I hate my
hair right now I want to cut my hair so
bad that's why I put a hat on in the
same boat well you know Phillip Phillip
we do see that they got the hair that
just starts flowing out eventually so oh
dude yeah I mean this is uh I got a mop
on my head right now like you read about
but no I mean I wouldn't say that I have
to like be a certain way or whatever cuz
people know me like and they wouldn't be
that wouldn't be tuning and if they
didn't and if somebody doesn't and they
tune in I would expect them to leave
within five seconds but um yeah I mean I
just think that for me it's a it's about
like having the most fun I mean I
wouldn't do the podcast if I didn't
think it was fun like you know me Chris
and Rob have such a great like
friendship and working relationship and
I think that we all genuinely enjoy
doing the show and you could tell when
you listen to it that's not always the
case when I'm streaming and I would do
that if I really was like you know the
best thing that you could possibly do is
do something you love and yeah I love
playing video games I do not love always
constantly being on stage because I like
to have that time for myself and I think
there's there's people who who love love
love doing that but you know I'm just
not that's not always me I'm like hit or
miss with it I'm hot and cold yeah do
you do you feel like you're kind of put
on
a little bit of like a stage when you
end up streaming because you know you're
coming you're coming back into the into
the life of streaming again a little bit
there's some times where I feel like I
do want to stream and there's some times
I'm like I don't want to stream and I
think like who'd want to watch this game
you know what I mean mm-hmm well what
will you
you've been playing a bunch of games in
your backlog you're kind of bringing
things back yeah because you know
because because college life college
life so um what uh what so what so like
what games have you been playing that
you feel that you shouldn't have to do
you don't want to stream a lot of
telltale games that I have yeah it's
like people wouldn't want to watch me
play this you know and I mean you people
just go to youtube and watch some
content creator that they really really
like they already have a walkthrough of
it mm-hmm do you feel like that kind of
like killed you from wanting to stream
that specific game or like many
different types of games um yeah I think
many type of games no no I didn't stream
after that after last week like I said
it would yeah yeah I mean it happens
like sometimes today earlier I mean I
always do a little bit of a stream
before this I had a little bit of ISP
problems and I was just like cursing out
my ISP that the whole entire time and I
was just like I had to cut the stream
earlier because of it and I I actually
thought of not streaming earlier because
I wanted to make sure I was I was ready
for poppadom so you know bring him on
here correctly and you know you know
have him be comfortable so yeah it's one
of those things I also like so I
actually I did stream one telltale game
and that was a telltale Game of Thrones
game which I thought was like the
biggest heap of garbage that I've ever
played I don't know if you're a big
telltale guy I'm Jay but I mean I like
die like telltale games yeah I do really
like Game of Thrones and that whole like
universe and I out of did you play
telltale Game of Thrones
I did not okay well if you feel like you
really just feel like being depressed
for like a real long time
play it because it is not good the story
the fam like the people that you're
playing as are just pathetic and it's
like every choice that you make is just
you can't make you can't win you just
can't win and yeah I was streaming that
and then I realized that I was like this
the entire time yep and I just couldn't
quit didn't do it well I still say the
best telltale game that was ever created
was the whole entire Walking Dead series
like yeah from start to finish like
sheriff they could have literally just
did the Walking Dead series from start
to finish and then called it because I
think they started going to other games
and was kind of started kind of
depreciating their value because The
Walking Dead was just it was it was so
good yeah I've heard those people really
love those games and they were really
trying to get them to save that series
right when telltale went under and you
know hopefully they got what they wanted
but oh boy did that game of thrones
games think I want you just kind of like
bring up bring it back a little bit to
you it's about a bunch of podcasts and
everything because um you know you the
podcast itself for you was it's
something that has grown and to the
point where you know I even listen to it
on a weekly basis I listen to a handful
of podcast every week one of them is
yours
i LP I listen to some of El boogies team
so I listen to a handful of different
podcasts every week and what do you
think was the number one thing that
helped you to have that to grow it's do
you mean like what did you think is the
number one thing that is help what is
your number one thing that you think
helped your your podcast to grow I think
the number one thing is just us being
genuine I think us being genuine and us
being consistent and I think I would
hope that you know anybody who's even at
the on the outside looking in would be
able to say those two things about us
we've been genuine and we've been
consistent we've never [ __ ] at
anybody we
never like we've never really had to
like like ask anybody for for really
anything I mean we've we've been
completely genuine we've done a really
good job of reaching out to guests and
having them come on the show and also be
themselves you know King was in like a
Corvette when he was on an episode of
our show live from e3 just like randomly
outside him at the top down and like
that was the most authentic thing that
I've ever seen we had asmin golden our
podcast big Wow streamer and we had him
give us a tour of his dirty ass for him
while he was on the show I was like duty
room really dirty or is this just like a
character that you play on Twitch and he
was like no bro look at this and it's
you know we've had we have had
developers we've had actors we've had
we've had you know streamers we've had
fellow podcasters and we've had hometown
friends who are just sitting there like
smoking cigarettes in their living room
surrounded by beer bottles shutters a
Juggalo collar correspondent Tyler bags
and people treat them all the exact same
way and I think that is what makes us
unique that's what makes us who we are
and that's what makes us so consistent
and genuine is because we don't give
anybody any special treatment or favor
or whatever like we'll roll out the red
carpet don't get me wrong I consider
myself the second best podcast introduct
introductory person or introducer right
behind Lord kognito himself of course
but the the fact of the matter is that
anybody who comes on the show you're
getting treated the same way we we treat
you like one of our hometown buddies and
vice versa
and people love that for the most part
we have never I mean we have never had
anybody come off the show and be like I
never want to talk to you guys again or
like that was embarrassing or like why
would you say something like that you
know we had an actor on the show
recently and you know we actually didn't
really think that he is like I actually
was getting was a little nervous just
kind of like about his personality and
whether or not it would mesh with ours
and you know he was a super cool guy he
liked and
being like more than happy to put up
with our antics and this was actor
daniel roebuck who played grease
treatise and Jedi fallen order and like
he's a pretty straight-laced guy he's a
professional he's been an actor for the
majority of his life he's forgotten more
about acting than most people will ever
learn he's a consummate professional and
we had him in there bullshitting with us
for an hour and a half I'm not other
gaming podcast and he was more than
happy to do it and you know it's stuff
like that but I think really sets us
apart and that's why people want to come
back on and that's why people want to
come and listen and that's why people
want to hang out in the discord and sit
in a voice channel named party daddies
and play piccolo and drinking with
people that they've never met it's
because they they value that type of
genuine attitude and they value that
type of authenticity and they value that
type of consistency and that's what they
get from us so as long as we keep that
up and and we never let them down and
that's something that I can can
confidently say that we've never done
then you know I look forward to seeing
us continue to grow and how long have
you guys been doing the podcast son so
the website started in 2016 so just
about four years old the podcast just
turned 3 earlier this year and you guys
and what what do you call it the the
daddy line before I know it's the the
wgg Internet dad's sauce line that is
our that is our voicemail box so you can
call the sauce line and you can leave
voicemails and we'll listen to them live
and respond live on the show and that's
something that we just started doing
like 10 episodes ago or not even and I
had to call that one time I'll leave you
a message and I wait I was doing about
like 75 80 on the highway when I'll stay
with that message and like I remember
you listening to it the next day and you
and you were just like he's do like a
buck 20 down the highway leave your
voice mail for us what is the Adams dam
and that's the type of stuff you can
like I think that's the type of stuff
that we bring out of people you know we
I mean you were there we recorded
so to the show live in some random like
storage room at PAX East 2020 with the
three of you guys and then the three of
us and we were just all just we were the
loudest people in that building by far
and God forbid we left those doors doors
open we would have all been all six of
us been escorted out and that's the type
of stuff that we bring out of people we
get people to be themselves at their
most animated at their most outgoing and
you know that's the type of stuff that
that I you know that makes me like
thankful that we started doing it in the
first place because it's just it makes
us feel good that people can can be
themselves like that with us I'm gonna
steal an MJ question because I know he
enjoys asking these questions when you
when you started streaming right and you
started doing the podcast everything
like that
what type of equipment did you do you
start with oh boy
so we started with Skype we used Skype
we all of us have like a strong 240p
video output all of us were using like
headphone mics and Skype and it sounded
like hot trash honestly like if you
could put your ear up to like a puddle
of like water that's been sitting in the
bottom of a dumpster and it's all like
rusty and [ __ ] and you just imagine what
that sounds like that's exactly what the
first couple episodes of the podcast
sounded like but now we all have mics
and we are using discord for video we
you know we've upgraded our audio and
video considerably you know and we've
kind of gotten a little a lot more
sophisticated over the years so yeah we
sounded like we were yelling at each
other through Dixie Cups the first a
couple episodes but we got better when
you when you guys kind of you've
collectively ended up going okay we
gotta upgrade the equipment like the
sound quality is what makes the
difference correct mm-hmm
yeah yeah yeah yeah MJ you can't you
kind of feel that way also
when it comes to like this podcast which
comes to streaming comes to all that
stuff yeah sometimes like I like the new
change that we
just made from the Google Hangouts yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm I'm really really
liking this that's change over the
quality is it feels a lot better and I
know that I've been push I've been
pushing cognitive change to zoom for a
while and what he said yeah and I kind
of told him I was like listen I'm like
I'm doing it I'm doing it for round
table I was like I'm like I'm just I'm
just gonna front the money to do a month
of it and see how it goes because I'm
like I think that you guys can kind of
benefit from it so it's kind of
something that he's looking into it also
and I love I love discord for voice
communications with people but like once
once like I tried doing the the video
chatting it seems like there's some
coding breakdown so it's like one of
those things that kind of like drove me
a little crazy and then like Google
Hangouts like half the time I had to
have Google Hangouts on on one screen
and then the podcast on another wand and
it was like all these settings have got
to get changed and I'm just like I'm
like this is gonna describes me a little
crazy I know el she she has no problem
when she ends up running it for for for
the ladies podcast I mean we have
problems sometimes but I don't know but
yeah you know how it is it's like we all
have to be our own personal tech support
people while we're ending up being
everything else so going back to Animal
Crossing Pete you you should start
playing it you buying me a switch no I'm
not using my stimulus check on a switch
right now for animal crossing you meet
it dumb what if what if I told you that
one of the neighbors you can get in the
game is a guinea pig I thought you were
the bio thought you were like the the
president of guinea pigs and now you're
over here saying I don't want to guinea
pig as a neighbor that's what I just
started listen I've been believe it or
not I've been talking to people about
putting them on the the same list as the
rabbits like because like you know how
rabbits and
a little tangent I'm good well fun you
know rabbits you cannot find them in any
pets for does it notice that yeah I
don't I don't know that but I believe
you so because they are under the same
there are some ruling over like
protected in like endangered type
species of like they don't want people
to not endangered species but they don't
want them to be sold in pet stores
because they're not properly like taken
care of and it's the same thing with
guinea pigs like they're not properly
taken care of and they're just like
milled in one place and then just just
like distributed where you can go to
like lots of different adoption agencies
so I've actually been like talking to a
whole bunch of different guinea pig
group channels to see if we can actually
get them under the same ruling so like
that's the type of stuff I do on the
side when what I'm not trying to write
articles for Lords of gaming's on net
stream all the time work not have my
wife murdered me because I'm always
playing video games and doing stuff and
apparently I get to spend some time with
my family every so often so so yes yeah
I try I try to do that but I won't get
you got to get me a picture of this
guinea pig this guinea pig neighbor okay
so I was wrong and I mean feel free to
crucify me for this because I'm sure
that you have never I'm sure that
nobody's ever done this so there is not
a specific guinea pig neighbor but there
are several hamsters do you know how
many times people call my guinea pigs
answers the window
all right listen there's like a second
we got one two three four we got like
this does like eight hamsters and you
could just I mean there are the cartoons
though they you could just say like oh
thanks hamsters in I got it right there
and I put the link in the chat much oh
this chat or chat yeah all wrong window
boom you just pick one right there oh
boy oh yeah I guess they do look mad
different that I mean these ones the
hamster neighbors look more like guinea
pigs though they don't look like
hamsters hamsters looks more like rats
I'm looking at him right now I'm sorry
for derailing this all
so you can cut all this out look more
like guinea pigs though tell me they
don't give me some give me some
bandwidth here because they look at this
they look more like guinea pigs and
hamsters this one has a pig nose look at
gram he's got a pig nose I put down
hamsters in Animal Crossing New Horizons
they look weird those they do they could
they could be made as JPEGs foam yeah
yeah exactly I can hear it I can hear
the switch being it shipped to your
house right now yes and then you'll hear
my wife smacking me in the face or
buying the switch as we're saving for a
house I literally when we got our checks
in for the IRS I went what am I gonna
use this money for I was ready to buy a
switch because it was right before we
were gonna PAX East and then I was like
upgrade my streaming box so I spent it
all on my streaming boxes Congrats not
even getting a refund check back because
I did not get one so congrats on the
wealth flex OTO dude well it's because I
have a business technically because I
you know I put all of my stuff for
streaming under taxes as per times I'm
sorry Bob should be doing he should be
putting his csgo crates under taxes as
expenses but but between my wife's
business and my business we ended up
getting my back so that's the only
reason why and we got and we got our
stimulus check in the mail over the
weekend which is nice but in the mail on
the online mail in the online mary the
new kids in the online and you call
yourself a technology guy you still hate
Animal Crossing listen I don't actually
hate Animal Crossing I just don't
understand the hype behind it I'm not
the type of person that's gonna run out
and yeah but do you get it now having
seen the hamster neighbors that kind of
look like any pigs
now I kind of get it I kind of alright
because they were adorable tell me now I
do I do but I also like like I was
telling you guys before I am a little
salty about Animal Crossing because of
PAX East because they tried to detain us
during press hour so I am a little salty
about that whole situation and I will
give an A+ to whoever that woman was
with us that smacked the the railing and
said you can't hold me here and walked
out like I commend her for that so that
was one of the funniest things I have
seen multiple people on Twitter speaking
of just one one last note on animal
crossing and then we can talk about what
else you want to talk about I have seen
multiple people like on Twitter and dis
could try to strategically arrange their
cuz you don't really get to pick like
who moves into your town like they'll
come by and they'll camp out and say
maybe I shouldn't move in or you can go
to other people's islands or like other
random islands in the game that are like
randomly generated and and like invite
people to come back to your Island and
move there full time and I've seen
people that have like full Islands full
of cats or like full of birds or full of
you know dogs or bears or whatever like
people love their animals so I'm just
saying if you're really I mean you're
like the foremost guinea pig guy I know
if you're really if you were really
about it then you would get Animal
Crossing and give yourself the whole the
whole island filled with them but until
that day comes I question your question
my wife was switch for for the
summertime when she has off and then I
will get animal crossing and then we can
play together love it that's that's the
old us feel nothing I'll get it go fun
snail calm yes the Manus which now that
TV go ahead and go right there and sub
so yeah that's that's good
you totally you definitely derail that
cuz you lost my train a lot so MJ do you
have any questions for Papa Tom no you
don't have any questions okay think of
one I want you to think of one come back
I'll come at you
well how about you
um did you already ask like I guess what
was like your favorite game as a kid
like what drew you in its like gaming I
did not feel down there you go give me
one second right hold on I know exactly
which one of this because you I'd assume
you're gonna pull out Mario and the
seven stars Super Mario RPG in the
legend of the seven stars for the Super
Nintendo Entertainment System this was
the first game that I ever beat as a kid
and this was the like I mean I was
probably man I mean I had to have been
eight of nine and this was the first
game where I ever got to like the end
screen and I did not understand what was
going on like I will never forget it for
as long as I live I beat the final boss
I remember this ice cream place too
because my parents took me there
afterwards they were going off ice cream
let's go and I was like all right let's
you know whatever and so I was afraid to
shut off the Nintendo because I was
afraid that I would lose everything and
there was credits there's like a big
parade at the end you know the credits
roll and then it says game over at the
end and game over for me he had only had
the connotation I've only seen a couple
of games that have said that like when
you beat it it was like thanks for
playing game over the game has ended and
I did not this this concept did not
process in my little seven or eight year
old brain we went off ice cream came all
the way back TV was still on game over
screen is still there I was like okay so
I hit a and went back to the save screen
fired up the thing again and I'm
standing right outside the final boss
room and I was like wait a minute that's
it like that game's end and it just blew
my little minds so this game I have been
lobbying for Nintendo to acknowledge it
and I have not I don't care what it is I
don't care what it is it could be a
remake it could be like a remaster it
could be a sequel it could be anything
more than Geno being an assist trophy in
Smash
give me a break okay this game is
fantastic it was a collaboration between
Nintendo and square at the Squaresoft of
time now Square Enix do you think about
your your all-time dream teams you have
Jordan and Pippen okay you have little
Wayne and Birdman on like father like
son you have you know I mean Bill
Belichick and Tom Brady and then you
have Nintendo and Squaresoft
on this beauty of a classic of a game
and this game changed who I was forever
and this is why I'm still into
role-playing games to this day this is
why I still have such a love for a
Nintendo in my heart and this is why I
have trust issues because I got to that
end screen and there was nothing after
it so the moral of the story kids is
always expect more okay and this is
where we're at right now this is why I
still have a copy of it this is why I
still keep it literally at arm's length
at all times because the game is a
goddamn classic this is the game that
works it's right next to it it's exactly
what I said but my wife is addicted to
earthbound I wanted to surprise her one
year and get her earthbound and I could
not find a working copy the one word
that's a lie I found a working copy but
it was $400 and I was like I love you
hon but here's an emulator because I'm
not doing $400 for for earthbound but
Mario that that version of Mario of the
seven stars I I never played it because
I never owned a Super Nintendo but I had
a friend that owned it and every time I
went over his house I ended up playing
it and the quality of it is it's one of
those games you never expected and it
was beautiful
beautiful um did you play what was the
was the game was it not Mario versus
rabbits there was Mario versus rabbits
kingdom battle it was like kind of like
the XCOM type gameplay I did not play
that but that I mean I would play it I
mean I just didn't want to like go out
and spend 60 bucks on it yeah pretty
sure take 10 on the eShop right now that
No
now it's like 10 bucks but it's like
it's like one of those games you never
expected to want to play and enjoy and
then you like you play it and you're
like oh this is this is way better than
you expected like I I started my RPG
life experiences with Final Fantasy the
original my brother and I literally let
it sit and play and never turned it off
until we did it like I was sitting like
my brother was playing and I had the
Nintendo power book flipping through it
page by page this is what you gotta do
next this is what you gotta do next to
beat it because that game sucked me an
RPG life it's awesome yeah I'm sorry I
totally hijacked your question now so MJ
did you did you have your question um
which next-gen system are you gonna get
are you gonna get them both I'm gonna
get a xbox probably I Adam an Xbox guy
I've never been a PlayStation guy I I
had a ps3 that's the only PlayStation
console that I've ever owned but as I
have said multiple times on our show I
was the kid in like middle school who
was like dude why do I need Grand Theft
Auto 3 when I can play Super Mario
Sunshine on my nintendo gamecube okay I
was playing Animal Crossing you know I
was playing luigi's mansion you know I
mean so and I always went over to like
my next-door neighbor's house and played
the PlayStation whenever I needed that
but um yeah I'm an Xbox guy you know I'm
I will probably get a gaming PC at some
point this year that's gonna be cool I'm
excited for that excited to stop being
shamed by our community that I don't
have one but I am looking forward to get
an Xbox I think that'll be really cool
and I haven't gotten like a new console
and probably about five years I still
have a launch model Xbox one in my
living room you know life's been moving
pretty quick over the last couple years
you know we got married we started
looking for a house so that has not been
in the budget plan just like a switch is
not it's now those budget plan right now
until now that he knows but yeah it's
gonna be an Xbox it's funny how you say
you have the one of the old
I think the og Xbox ones like the fur
because I have I have the same one and I
the only reason why I booted it up was I
I played Division one on it and then I
played a little bit of Division two on
it and then after that I
yeah I've said this for for like
probably about two years now whatever
thing whatever piece of hardware is
gonna provide me the best experience to
play Halo infinite on is what I'm going
to purchase is that is that what is that
what you kind of mostly mostly are
anticipating like is that legging you're
anticipating to play the most right now
oh yeah a hundred percent a hundred
percent
mm-hmm is that you feel oh no play Halo
but I'm not like not one of those
diehard fans like I know so many are out
there you know yeah I mean let's put it
this way I mean like I definitely want
to play infinite right when it comes out
and if it launches in the same days that
Xbox it's gonna force my hand but
there's just nothing and Ike halo for me
probably hasn't been like a console
seller since like halo 3 but there's
also just nothing on the other side that
doesn't that like kind of sway me away
from it I was even considering
potentially getting a PC and because I'm
sure that infinite is gonna be on PC as
well they're just playing that with a
controller because I prefer controller
mouse and keyboard another thing that
people just put me up on the cross for
but um you know that's just what I
prefer but I wanna be able to play with
my boys I want to be able to play with
my brother love them playing Halo with
since he was like old enough to even
hold a controller and know what colors
or buttons were what so as long as I can
do that and if I can do that on PC great
because great because if I can play with
like Xbox friends that would be fine but
yeah whatever's gonna be the best halo
infinite experience is what is what I
will be acquiring this holiday season I
guess you got two questions for you I
just thought I just thought of a really
interesting one do you end up co-op
gaming at all with your with your missus
uh
a little bit here and there she likes
platformers like we played through we
beat Donkey Kong Country Returns on in
Tendo swish another great reason to buy
that console great game report we played
through that she really should really
like that so we like to caught the coop
platformers so I'm trying to get her to
play a cup head with me right now and
see how we do with that but hey good
luck on that yeah I don't know if I want
to do that because we were already
luckily in Donkey Kong you can like
literally carry the other person so if
there's any literally makes it harder if
you add another person all right yes
we're not gonna be doing that but yeah
the co-op games are cool that's like the
only game that I've ever like what like
came home to like walk in on her playing
like on her own without me being like
hey do you want to play this game so
she's not like a huge gamer but yeah
platformers and stuff like we played
Little Big Planet and stuff when that
was on ps3 um you know the Mario co-op
game she digs so all the classics really
ever played Laurie yeah mm-hmm is it
already co-op or it's not co-op I don't
think but um you can do like speed
trials against each other and then it's
just like a good story like I know I
don't mean in the plan or its I saw the
trailer the trailer for the sequel looks
absolutely beautiful so I really wanted
I think the first one still on game
pastuzo forgetting piss what I laugh
about all the time is how people are
amazed that the development studio that
made Ori they don't have an actual
studio all of them work from home and
then they just Mel I like everything to
one person or they're all collaborative
in one way and they've produced all of
their games that way which is pretty
damn amazing
absolutely absolutely yeah Ori looks
absolutely beautiful I wanted I'm gonna
gotta make some time and play that so
okay well we're gonna we're gonna end up
you know ending up what we're gonna do
here so Dom why don't you kind of tell
us where we can end up off finding
tell us everything about you Pete
absolutely I would love to do that as
you may have already heard this is me my
name is Dom you know me as Papa Dom if
you listen to the podcast or uncle Tommy
or wherever wherever you whatever you
like whatever comes to mind the turn of
whisper you can find me on Twitter at
Uncle Tommy it's at Uncle Tommy's pretty
easy you can find us wicked good gaming
on Twitter at at wicked good games
wicked good gaming comm if you want that
premium handcrafted written content you
get new blogs every single day for the
last four years so you know you're gonna
find something good on there every time
you go on and if you want to find the
podcast it is called not another gaming
podcast we have just passed our
three-year anniversary episode 176 is
coming at you this week and that is
going to be as always over at twitch.tv
slash wicked good gaming not another
gaming podcast every single Thursday 9
o'clock Eastern Time p.m. and you can
find this also on Spotify Apple podcast
Google Play Music stitcher TuneIn Radio
overcast and now radio calm and I Heart
Radio so you can check us out on all
those platforms wherever you find
podcast not another gaming podcast and
wicked good gaming calm and thank you
guys for having me on well thank you
very much for stopping in we'll probably
be seeing you in a couple more weeks and
I will tell everyone you have to go
listen to these guys that is funny the
group collaboration and the the
camaraderie between all of them it's
great and it's funny you shouldn't you
should definitely go and hear them MJ
where can we find you good sir on me on
Twitter
and baby MJ same thing as an Instagram
might which is MJ is a boss my snapchat
is a beat 101 and you can also find me
on Lords gaming dotnet my what is the
PlayStation Plus get free games of the
month and the xbox live games with gold
you know the best articles on the Lords
Gaming Mouse doozy in the chat over
there he knows we all know we all know
okay well thank you very much good sir
uh L what about you work we find you I
am on mixer Tuesday through Friday
either from 7:00 to 8:00 as usually when
I start I go to about 10:00 and then on
Saturdays I'll go gaming on YouTube of
course Monday here and I forgot to tell
you but I'm now a member of the cookout
so yeah what is the cookout it's just
like a group community group for people
of color type of thing and all kind of
content creators artists people to play
video games people that cook like do all
kind of stuff but like they started
mainly on Twitch and now they're
branching out to like mixer people - oh
cool I like that they're doing that it's
like a networking thing you know yeah
that's cool we need we need more of
those we need to get more of this going
here - so yeah and everyone knows myself
I'm snow though SN al why do you can
catch me on everything
twitch YouTube Twitter all that fun
stuff go check out my twitch got a
really really nice subscriber giveaway
going on right now my community actually
gave it up to to us so go check us out
at that time I was usually between 7:00
and 10:00 Monday to Friday except for
one more here say thank you very much
there and I also want you to say thank
you papa Dom for coming in today and
hanging out and like I said earlier in
the show we're gonna be getting you know
your other crew members in here for the
rest of the week and then all of you
guys together at the end of the you know
after we get everyone together and like
I said before we're gonna have this up
on Wednesday morning thank you everybody
you know an iTunes Spotify Google
podcast stuff like that if anyone has a
question for any of the people that are
coming on please email us at round table
stream team at gmail.com I check it very
often and remember to follow us on a
table stream
you know it's a roundtable with the
stream team was way too long for Twitter
it did not like that and make sure you
guys are checking out the iron Louis
podcast at 1:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time and check out all of our articles
that Lords of gaming dotnet for more
news and make sure you guys you know
keep an eye on our Twitter for when
we're going live who's gonna be coming
on all that fun stuff alright and thank
you everyone and remember to dream big
and keep gaming and we will see everyone
next week everyone bye thanks again